Oh calm down it's just a joke okay so
this month's lgbtq+ a related video is
going to be um a little bit more
tangential than usual because while the
topic that I'm about to talk about does
touch on lgbtq+ representation and I'll
be using those kinds of examples overall
this is about the biggest and broadest
version of a core question and it
stretches beyond those and that question
being who can make what jokes now what
got me thinking about this is that
earlier this year I made a guest
appearance on a podcast that a friend of
mine and occasional guest on this
channel
Ryan Daley puts out it's called cheers
cast and on it he's going through every
episode of the sitcom cheers and talking
about each of those with a guest the one
he had me on for was from season one it
was an episode called the boys in the
bar
now it's an episode structured very
centrally around gay men and the concept
of gay bars and the prejudices that come
out of some of the characters when it
comes to those topics Ryan was very
upfront with me about the fact that he
had me on because I talk about lgbtq+
representation and am part of that
community gender fluid if you didn't
know and Ryan being a straight sis guy
he didn't feel comfortable making
determinations about whether or not the
jokes in the episode were offensive or
held up and even if it wasn't the ideal
perspective since I'm not a gay man but
hey you know you'll work with the circle
of friends you have so having this
conversation with Ryan got me thinking
more about the minefield of what jokes
are or aren't okay to tell and I'm sure
this topic won't incur any wrath from
anybody at all art
topics fun chapter one no laughing
matter so the first thing that needs to
be acknowledged is that this issue quite
simply doesn't have an easy answer and
that in and of itself actually
contributes to the problem of trying to
even talk about it because you see when
folks ask questions like what jokes are
okay to tell they really want a nice
simple answer something clean and easily
understood just simple rules that apply
to everybody in the same way and that
aren't just on a case-by-case thing well
if you're gonna be honest about the
reality involved you can't do that and
I've dealt with the problems of an over
simple of over simplified view of
complicated things before specifically
what I talked about the question of
whether or not only trans actors should
be allowed to play trans characters
there as here the entire thing involves
a lot of nuance a ton of context and
that context often shifts drastically on
a case-by-case basis so many people want
it to boil down to either look either
people can be joked about or they can't
either everybody is allowed to tell any
joke or nobody gets to tell that joke
you can't have it both ways
Oh a world free of context would be so
simple this kind of thing only works on
an even playing field where all groups
are on comparable standing both
historically and representationally and
that is just not the world we live in
maybe one day but not yet and trying to
behave as if things are equal when they
aren't that's how the status quo gets
entrenched so we can't take the overly
simplistic route we need to inject some
nuance into this sucker chapter two
context is everything since I'm not
going to be arriving at a neat and tidy
conclusion let me get my broad feelings
in here early so folks at least have a
set of the mindset that I am approaching
this thing from basically I agree with
the following quote from the late great
George Carlin
he said I believe you can joke about
anything it all depends on how you
construct the joke and ultimately I
think that is the closest we can get to
an answer to this question that is short
and pithy I am of the mind that any
topic is fair game however not every
target is fair game and whether or not
it is depends heavily on who is telling
the joke now it should go without saying
that this is always going to be
execution dependent if the joke isn't
actually funny then really noting that
none of this even matters you already
tripped up the first hurdle and broke
your nose in the fall
so let's now distinguish between the
topic of a joke and the target of a joke
because it is true that nearly every
joke ultimately is at the expense of
somebody be they individual or group I
mean think in terms of a punch line the
punch has to be aimed at somebody so to
bring it back to that episode of cheers
that I mentioned I felt that it held up
extremely well precisely because of this
distinction gay men were the topic of
the overarching joke of that episode but
they weren't the target the target was
ultimately the people expressing the
prejudice so the big final joke of the
episode involves gay men without gay men
being the punchline in the end of the
episode the punchline is at the expense
of norm who is the character displaying
prejudice most prominently throughout
the episode this isn't to say that gay
men actually can't also be a target and
have it work but that's where the added
context of who's telling the joke and
why they're telling it comes into play
it's a well remarked phenomenon that
people are empowered to laugh at their
own community their own culture to a
degree that those outside of that
community and culture aren't oftentimes
that has to do with just knowing enough
about a community or culture to send it
up properly
Concha points pointed this out in a
video where she noted that people
outside of a given group often lack the
knowledge to make any observations or
jokes about that group beyond the most
obvious ones so often jokes made about
say gay people by straight people or
about trans people by sis people or
whatever are just really lazy and
obvious and tired because the joke
teller doesn't know enough about their
target to go beyond surface level and
you're left with a very shallow and
clumsy joke and that's that's tripping
out the first hurdle again so to turn
that around though from my vantage point
there's often something of a pass given
to joke tellers who come from within the
targeted group even if the jokes aren't
very good and I speak from experience
here because I've been to plenty of
comedy shows I've seen gay male comics
make broad obvious stereotyping jokes at
the expense of gay men jokes that don't
get called out and would go over very
poorly if they were somebody straight
comedian with no standing in the lgbtq+
community again this doesn't mean the
obvious joke that these comics tell
suddenly works just because they are
also gay but the joke failing isn't
usually looked upon as harshly because
of who's saying it well that's the
theory anyway let's take a look at it
and practice let's talk about what
happened earlier this year with Kevin
Hart and the Oscars so to recap quickly
in case you forgot comedian Kevin Hart
was originally tapped to host the 2019
Academy Awards some old comedy routines
and homophobic tweets were brought up
and he ultimately pulled out of the gig
I don't actually want to talk about that
series of events but to get to my actual
point the context is necessary as it
always is so in the wake of all this
Nick Cannon attempted to defend Hart by
dredging up some tweets by comedian
Sarah Silverman in which similar
homophobic language appeared cannon
basically was asking the question that
if she's not being punished for this
then why is heart it was fairly swiftly
pointed out by several prominent members
of the lgbtq+ community that Silverman
had long been an active ally
participating in cherries and in
charities and advocating for their
rights Kevin Hart has not now that
doesn't make one of them an inherently
better person but it does mean that
Silverman has standing within the
community
she has social capital goodwill and has
earned benefit of the doubt and heart
hurt just doesn't have that and that's
not a criticism of him as a person it's
just the fact Silverman and a number of
other noted comedians such as Kathy
Griffin and the late Joan Rivers would
frequently make incredibly obscene jokes
about gay men at fundraising events for
gay causes and it was considered to be
okay because the targets of the joke
knew that these were not coming from a
place of hate
due to the background and history and
context of the person saying it so while
canons attempt to defend heart may have
been well intentioned it didn't take the
full context of the speakers into
account and that stripping out of
context really is the big hang-up when
these arguments about jokes blow up it's
usually because one or both sides of the
debate are either failing to account for
or are simply willfully ignoring the
full and proper context because the
problem is never truly just the joke in
and of itself chapter three base
assumptions context isn't the only thing
that gets murky in all this because
there's another element at play and that
is the answer to the question what are
the base assumption of the joke a base
assumption is something that is taken as
a given in the context of a joke it's
something that is presumed the audience
already knows about or a perspective
that is presume they agree with all
jokes have base assumptions because
otherwise comedians who have to explain
every single element of the joke as they
go and it would take forever and it
wouldn't be funny I
at a basic level think of any priest and
a rabbi joke
it wouldn't work if the person listening
didn't already know what those things
are on some level or how any topical
joke assumes the audience already knows
about the celebrity or event or news
item that's being referenced
additionally sometimes the base
assumption is that certain things are
inherently funny or at least will be to
an audience that the joke is being told
to think about how much humor is built
on the presumed inherent humor value of
a fart or a small child swearing or just
getting hit in the face with a pie the
presumed shared pieces of knowledge and
inherent comedic values are examples of
base assumptions that jokes will get
built on they're not the jokes itself
but the jokes stand on the foundation of
them so I'm gonna take a look at two gay
jokes one that I feel falls on its face
and one that holds up surprisingly well
despite its age however both operate on
certain base assumptions that are kind
of problematic
regardless firstly from Mel Brooks's
history of the world part one we have
the scene with the Roman Emperor and he
has an assistant who is mincing and
effeminate and eventually this
culminates in the Aaron Burr turning
around and going okay what's next now
part of the impact of the joke is the
shock value not of the actual word which
would now be shocking more than was then
but actually just the opening knowledge
'men at all because for context it needs
to be pointed out that these kinds of
characters appeared all the time but
were rarely ever openly acknowledged as
gay by slur or otherwise it's a holdover
from the Hays Code which was a set of
self-imposed rules Hollywood operated
under from 1930 to 1968 and I've talked
about it before but filmmakers weren't
supposed to ever depict gay characters
on screen or at least they were not
supposed to admit that that was what
they were doing
but setting shock value aside the big
problem with this entire bit is that it
operates on the basis that one only game
an act this way and to stereotypically
effeminate gay men are simply inherently
comedic his limp wrists his Lisp his
cooing they're treated as an inherent
joke as things that are deserving a
mockery just for their existence these
behaviors wouldn't be on display for as
long as they are otherwise if it wasn't
believed that they were inherently funny
it doesn't need to be drawn out for the
shock joke to work boy
when you die at the palace you really
die at the palace now contrast that with
the famous final joke from some like it
hot
now that film centers around two men who
masqueraded women in order to hide out
from the mob now one of those men played
by Jack Lemmon finds himself on the
receiving end of another man's affection
this one played by Joe Brown at the end
of the film as these two characters
speed off in a boat Lemmon still just as
a woman keeps giving reasons he hopes
will cause Brown to break off his
romantic pursuit Lemmon says that he
smokes he says he can't have children
but when nothing works he finally pulls
off the wig and declares I'm a man well
nobody's perfect
that is genius that final punchline said
kind of affection by a man who fell in
love with somebody and doesn't really
care what that person's gender is
honestly the punchline is so delicate it
can almost feel like it doesn't have a
target at all it is an adorable sweet
and immensely funny payoff to the entire
relationship it is a truly brilliant
joke but it does still operate on a
troublesome base assumption which is
that Browns response is only funny
because it is unexpected and
inappropriate the joke great as it is
only works if it's assumed that the
correct response would have been
revulsion or confusion or basically
anything other than what we see it
assumes that a man upon learning he was
attracted to another man should be
disgusted and the unexpected divergence
from that is what makes it funny
accurate for the time though that
assumption maybe it is unpleasant all
the same when you actually break it down
chapter for most humor ages like milk
now I didn't dig into that last example
intending to ruin a great joke but
instead to point out one of the
underlying reasons behind why humor very
frequently does not age very well
because it's not just shock humor that
ages poorly honestly it's most jokes
period and a major reason is that our
base assumptions as a society shift we
come to better understandings of people
common knowledge be it shifts to a
different place and the acceptable
standards shift along with it old
assumptions become outdated and get
discarded the result being that jokes
which depended on the old assumptions
become either ineffectual or
cringe-inducing this is the source of
that rather trite observation you
couldn't tell that joke today
now most people say that as a
condemnation of an overly sensitive PC
society but I would argue that it is in
a case of you can't tell that joke today
but it's more cases of that joke doesn't
work anymore because the base
assumptions the thing is built on are no
longer the accept
truth and then the whole thing just
falls apart let's take a few more
contrasting examples just to play this
out in practice everybody likes my
Python right I know I do love those
crazy Brits and last year I want to
express my adoration for life of Brian's
specifically and I forget what video or
maybe it was a livestream I was asked
about whether or not a specific
character in it was a vehicle for a
transphobic humour so in life a Brian
Baer is a character who was initially
presented as Stan he's part of a
dysfunctional political group called the
people's front of Judea who opposed the
Romans near the start of the bcad
changeover and there's a point early on
where Stan expresses a desire to be a
woman what I want to be a woman from now
on I want you all to call me Loretta and
it's very much meant to be humorous
here's why I personally feel the joke
works even now and again others may take
offense I am not saying I'm the end-all
be-all authority on this this is just my
perspective while initially confused
Loretta's friends are actually pretty
accepting of the general idea of her
being a woman and even later in the film
we see moments of them doing their best
you properly gender her and apologizing
for a slip-up the only point of specific
mockery is that part of the reason why
Loretta wants to be a woman is that she
wants to have babies which of course is
a physical impossibility and also not a
reason any real-world trans woman
undergoes a transition it's such an
absurd reason for wishing to transition
that it comfortably lands as a parody of
wishing for an unrealistic outcome which
fits in directly with the broader parody
that is the people's front of Judea as a
whole because this is a group with
deeply unrealistic goals a very nebulous
agenda and ineffectual means of
achieving any of it and the group
ultimately resolves that even though
Loretta
can't have baby she can
have the right to have babies and they
will fight for that as pointless as it
would actually be in practice again I
don't believe it to be a joke targeted
at the expense of a trans person it is a
broader joke that is about this kind of
political group and it's using a trans
character to illustrate an aspect of
that and the base assumptions about
poorly organized political movements are
well that they're still pretty solid
even now now let's contrast that with
the classic mind Python sketch the
lumberjack song would you as iconic as
it is does ultimately end up being a
case of the very idea of a man in
women's clothes as funny hahaha and with
increasing understanding of gender
identities and how arbitrary many
suppose it masculine or feminine traits
are the basic assumptions of this sketch
they do not hold up any more oh and if
anybody's wondering about the fact that
the Pythons often play female characters
usually dowdy old women I don't consider
that to be transphobic either because
they're not playing trans characters
they're flat-out playing women the fact
that they're clearly men as to the
absurdity of whatever it is going on and
in those sketches the fact that they're
being played by men is never the joke or
even really an aspect of it you could
have had the same sketches done with
actual female actors and the jokes play
exactly the same I don't have a great
transition for this next point I'm about
to make but it needs to be addressing so
here we go
chapter 5 punching down humour so
circling back to the target of a joke
there's also the issue of punching down
humor which is a practice most people do
consider to be in poor taste
broadly speaking punching down humor is
when someone with privilege tells jokes
at the expense of people lacking that
same privilege now in the interest of
not opening up the debate of what is or
isn't privileged because that's
conversation that would
completely overtake this video let me
lay out a hypothetical example that I
think most folks can roll with let's say
that a comedian was well known for being
a millionaire that's a big part of their
persona it's a widely known fact about
them they base a good chunk of their act
around that fact actually you know
scratch that let's just say that Jeff
Bezos decided he's gonna try his hand at
stand-up comedy there we go so now
imagine his set is built primarily
around telling jokes about the homeless
and the unemployed and people on food
stamps people who need to work overtime
or work two jobs to get by imagine his
punchlines questioning the value of
those people their importance and their
intelligence a man with preposterous
amounts of money joking that people with
less than him must must be worthless
idiots basically you really should have
thought of that before you became
peasants without the layer of irony that
that possibly is purest level would be
the essence of punching down humour
someone on firm standing picking on
someone they consider to be beneath them
it's the nobles mocking the peasants
there aren't a ton of universal rules in
comedy but don't punch down is one of
the few most agree on unless it's
actually their goal to piss off the
audience now sometimes a comedian might
actually get away with punching down
humour depending on who the target group
is and whether or not there are any
members of said group in the audience
ie Jeff Bezos could probably get away
with telling those jokes and a roomful
of other billionaires but that could
also lend a false sense of it being okay
in the broad sense only for it to bite
him in the ass when he tries to play
those exact same jokes in a more diverse
crowd than he's used to likes a local
coffee house had an open mic this is
another factor that contributes to the
phenomenon of aging comedians complain
about how their old routines don't fly
anymore they have a tendency to peg this
on artificially enforced political
correctness but I would posit that they
are playing to crowds that are either
diverse enough that the groups they're
making jokes about are now actually
present and those people aren't just
smiling and nodding quietly anymore
I mean notice how many aging comments
complain about college crowds we live in
an age where thanks to things like
social media underprivileged people feel
more empowered to speak up than has
historically been the case where things
get muddy again is that issue of what
does or doesn't qualify one group as
being more privileged than another which
is why I did the entire hypothetical
thing with Jeff Bezos because I'm pretty
sure nobody who'd have an actual
good-faith disagreement with me on the
overall points I'm making would argue
that example being anything other than
the privilege of picking on the under
privilege it made the point but in
reality we don't have such universal
agreement as to what qualifies as
privilege or indeed whether or not
privilege is even a thing in the first
place it is by the way and on the far
ends of these conversations are always a
few who knowingly engage in punching
down humor in order to fall deliberately
into trying to offend people because
there are always gonna be some people
who will immediately do the thing they
have been told not to simply because
they have been told not to do it I think
you may have accidentally stumbled
across an actual universal rule right
there huh Gomi chapter six conclusion so
yeah like I said at the start I don't
have a simple one to give you much like
life in general
it's complicated there's a lot of play
when the question of what jokes can be
told and who can tell them comes up
there's who's telling the joke what's
the topic of the joke who's the target
of the joke how well does the speaker
understand
the target group or individual what
assumptions does the joke depend on is
the speaker engaging in punching down
humour and other stuff that I'm honestly
probably not even thinking to account
for now that's a heck of a lot to have
to try and juggle in order to just try
and make people laugh and humans are
nothing if not lazy we don't want to
make those kinds of calculations every
time we want to tell a joke
so we strip out the context and you we
yell the resulting punchy soundbite at
each other which only fuels the anger
because when people take simplistic
opposing far-end views they will never
find middle ground and for the that very
reason I don't have a nice punchy finish
to this thing because punchlines are
hard and I am no comedian so jokes who
gets to tell them have I broken this
down in a way that makes any sense
am i completely off my rocker if you
want to disagree with me I welcome it I
would encourage you to do so politely
however whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comment let's talk
about it you can support this channel on
patreon it he'll it helps me cover my
bills and grow this channel into
something bigger better and more
ambitious plus there's the like and
subscribe always there much appreciate
the like button especially has been a
big help lately there's other links down
there additionally as well check them
out click on them they will take you
places but you also don't have to
because just like I couldn't tell you
exactly how to parse this question I'm
not going to tell you what to do with
those links either because at the end of
the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]